Okay, welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone. Before we introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some rules and logistics. First of all, please mute yourself during the talk unless you have questions. If you have questions, you're welcome to unmute and ask. Otherwise, please use the chat room to post your questions so that we can address them in q&a session at the end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to external audiences, there are no classify this question aloud. And finally, the talk today will be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about it. Now, let me introduce our speaker today. honor to host the Jianchao who is a Cardis Collins professor at Northwestern specializing in innovative manufacturing process and systems particularly in the areas of deformation based processes and laser additive manufacturing manufacturing processes. She's the founding director of the University Research Center on manufacturing Science and Innovation at Northwestern known as an MC served as an Associate Vice President for Research at Northwestern from 2012 to 2021. She has co authored over 250 journal articles 20 patents and the several opinion opinion articles. cow has been the editor in chief of journal of materials processing, processing technology since 2018. And Professor cow is an elected member of the National Academy of Engineering, a fellow American Association for Advancement of Science and many other organizations. And she's, she's the recipient of many prestigious awards as well, including ASME had political applied mechanics or Word and ASME Milton show Manufacturing Research medal. She served as the president of the SME North American manufacturing of Research Institute, Chair of ASME manufacturing engineering division and the program director at the National Science Foundation. So today, Professor cow will talk about physics based AI assisted design and control in flexible manufacturing. Please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk. Now, without further ado, let me pass the baton to Professor cow by asking one random question. As usual, today's random question is, what is your idea of the perfect day? Perfect days today? Yeah, every day is the perfect Yes, that's awesome. Okay, great. Thank you very much for the invitation. And so, my goal of this talk is to share some high level of the activities of what we do. So in our lab, we have been, you know, looking at both in numerical simulations as well as developing innovative manufacturing processes. So that intersection is really interesting. So what I'm the goal is to share, as I said, the you know, the high level activities and hopefully to derive some new in detail the discussions later on. So, here's the email address, which is the best way to reach me and with that, let me move forward. So, the ultimate goal of our lab is really looking starting from the materials looking at the PSPP in a process structure property relationships, and the material is a base for you know, manufacturing processes right. And then when we added in are those innovative process and machine designs, the reason that we want to design all mache is a bill of capability of say imposing a new metrology system so we can have the data that we can analyze, knowing that the details about how those data were generated, right, as well as being able to develop a new processes, it's hard to do a process development with a specific instrumentation and meanwhile, also to feed back to the process to do the control. And then the other part is that design and design many times you can have looking at just product material and process design Secretary The ultimate goal of our lab as well as my collaborators here at Northwestern, as well as me nationwide, is trying to also think about CO design of these different aspects. And find that I, you know, very well is a qualification or certification that will be needed for this. So overall, linking all these together is a simulation and data. So what we have been doing also last year with my colleague, Professor when can live and, again, is to look at the, how AI and mechanics work together to drive the things that I talked about earlier for process design for process modeling, and for process control. So, what I would do is, in this talk, I'm going to talk about these three aspects. To show how we do that using additive metal additive manufacturing, as example. As well as some at the very end, I'm going to show some flexible sheet metal forming process, which is really complementary very well with metal additive. So with that, too, you know, what I want to show you this, this is our home built, laser additive mushy. And this is we call it additive rapid prototyping instrument RP. What it does is a powder, Brom laser additive process directed energy deposition. And for this particular one, you know, you can see the environmental chamber, living lasers, and what's up here, actually, I have a more detail the ones later on, is this one. So, this one, we have RP from the backside, we also have four different, you know, hoppers from Potter motion maps, as well as two of those. So we can deposit different materials, right. So this is one examples that you deposit, you know, for different, Steel's and, and you can also mix it with that, the key questions that we want to ask is, What about other mechanical properties that are generated from that deposition. Certainly, porosity is of the concern. And what we did, by being close to Argonne National Lab, we put the DD system into argon, the high density, high speed X ray imaging of the DD. So what you can see is that deposit right here, deposit layer here, and the X ray imaging weather and we developed a high throughput, you know, sample sample drum, as well as the deposition, such that we can get lots of data changing the process parameter to see what's happening. And just a glance about you know, the setup are gone. So, so it's not curved that just because of the picture is taken in the in the panoramic view, right. But the key thing is, you know, if you look at the powder is flowing down, and this is the male pool, and many people have been doing this for the powder bed for the DD, we were among the very first group actually doing that. So, but the key thing in there so the we did a lot of analysis of this for this particular group, what I want to say is, the key thing that didn't notice is also the male pool dynamics right male pool is important in terms of how the porosity is generated inside the inside the belt, and specifically we find out for our particular application with a DD is because you're carrying a lot of gas actually into the male pool. So the male put depths in addition to typically Paderborn people looking at the width and the length. So, for the the the depths is actually equally important. So, because of that, you know, investigation, therefore, from the numerical point of view as well as from the practical point of view, we say okay, how can we control the MailPoet depth during the buildup? So the way that we do it is, if you look at our experimental setup, you can look at the I find that the width and the length right, but the depths is information is not that visible, but numerical simulation can. So we develop our own in house new numerical simulation code called gamma. And, and based on this, this is a thermal summit some thermal thermal code basically. And you can you can see that based on the temperature, you can find out what is a map with depth. What's new here is in the simulation, we use the MailPoet depths as our target objective function, and the build up the closed loop control and change the input which is a laser power in the simulation. So, as a result, the opposite of this is using one simulation, the output is a laser power history, such that you can control the MailPoet depths, wherever you are, right. So, this method is much more general in the sense in terms of the geometry, or material property or material types that you're doing. And, because of this, you know, what we did, here's a quick glance about the FTM code gamma. And as it here's a governing equation, which is pretty standard. And the the key part for our particular application is we need the speed in order to do this cross loop control to generate the laser power. So, it's being implemented with Parsa and and Q pi is used for GPU acceleration. So that we can do this very, very good. And you can see that you know, if you have the constant laser power moving forward, as you build up the heat got accumulated, therefore, the MailPoet depth is also getting to be higher and higher, but with the the constant control the ones that laser power, so, domain is changing as decreasing as you could imagine, and for the Melco depths is very well controlled. So, we implement this to our experiments RP instrument, and you can see also, you know, the the heat, the colorization kind of index about you know, how good is heat accumulation, and also you can use our camera from the side to also indicate that what's interesting is also looking at properties right. So, what we did is particularly to see if the goal is whether you can have location specific control, so, we build up a box and one side of the box has a target male put that as a two millimeter the other side that's a 1.4 millimeter different depth, we know that the depth is different thermal history will be different or some material property will be different right. So, and and that's basically using the simulation two I mentioned earlier to build up the laser laser history and we build the box and this is a and b and once from the outside the geometry you know, they look pretty similar, but so, we cut the tensile specimen from A and B and then you pull it in so, the stress strain curve, the material behavior for a and b are very different as you can see, right. So, this is interesting in the way because sometimes many times we do component design and sometimes you want a different microstructure at different locations to get to the properties you want for you know, creep resistance for strength, you have different design. So, this gives you a way to say you know, using the additive manufacturing you can actually put the different properties is the as you need it. One thing also interesting from this one is that particularly if you are a material scientist, you know, you look at this curve, you say okay, a I have a deeper male pool, which means you know, I will have a slower cooling rate and which means potentially, I may have you know, a larger grid size and therefore, you know, a should be lower than B. So, why this A is higher than B, you know, so, we specifically actually make sure that we got the specimen at the right location, what the interesting came out is that the additive you know, so what we did hear they say we just build up the wall and cut mini specimens at these different portion of the wall. And we also use our camera to record the time history at different points, and then just purely using the data driven approach to see, you know, what is the significance of those time thermal history that will influence the properties, the tensile properties right here. So, we've done quite a lot of different you know, checking out different machine learning tool, and this random forest actually comes out to be pretty interesting. So, what it does is we put every 50 degree in terms of the time you spend in that 50 degree interval, and then correlate to the strengths say tensile strength of the material, and this plot shows the, you know, relevance importance. So, what's interesting for impurities data driven was it has two different temperature regions has the most effect in terms of the property. And the first one, if you look at this, the first one is very much related to the measure the liquidus to solidus temperature. So basically, solidification rate, and this is what we were trying to control, right, if we're not controlling the MailPoet depth, and, and this is a direct control indication of that, but the second part is equally important in this is actually very much corresponding to the standard heat treatment temperature. So, what this tells us is that the final property that we are getting is a combination of how you submit the fire as well as additional heating time that you have this material point is experiencing, right? So if you do that, you know, you can come up with just a fitting function right here. And we use those walls you know, we actually fit it and it's kind of very interesting to see also microstructure wise it fits this kind of conclusion, one thing is about the spacing which is basically the other one that he trimmer is also about these additional Delta phase generated that cut to the Britto lover phases, and they're helped to strengthen the material properties right. So, from here, what we are saying is okay, we can't just do multiple control, we actually need to control the thermal history and thermal history is very challenging things to control right? Because it's a highly dimensional temporal and spatial design. So, the way that we do it we say okay, if we want to control thermal history, the local location specific control that in the previous approach is not going to be enough. So, the way that we do it, we use the so called differentiable simulation. And basically we rewrite our Gamma code in using the differentiable simulation, which is basically we use the deep learning library for this particular ratio, particular application, we use the Tai Chi one, but also in another one that we are doing right now we use Jack's which is developed by Google basically, in those libraries that we got with a with a EES or tai chi or jacks, it has it has the graph representation about this partial differentiable simulation, right, partial differential equation and use a graph what it can do is it can give you the gradient information for free where you are doing the forward analysis. So it's automatic differentiation provided by those libraries and help us to compute basically this Cobian that you know, traditionally you have to do it by yourself. So so it's a gradient based continuous optimization and people have been used using differentiable simulation for robotics path planning, as well as you know, this is becoming really popular these days to also look at the the fluids, you know, heat transfer as we have it right here. So, for us, you know, this is what I mentioned earlier, right? We use these tools to To develop the another tool that for our manufacturing process design, so, what it does it can come on the physics space the simulation, and then what we do is we represent the laser power using a neural network. And here you can think about these are all partial differential equations, in which you can put everything together under a global optimization framework. And with that, what we can say is if I want to have specific thermal history, I can use the you know, run this overall simulations and get that what you want. So, the key idea is, we represent the laser power as a time series and go through the FTM simulation which is differentiable, get the thermal history, and then we do the optimization. So, for example, with this thin wall, and multiple points, if the blue is what we want, and we feeding to the Adam atomization to to basically framework and then create the laser power as this red line. Versus if it's constant, it's a green you know, so, as you can see the green the thermal response from different points are very different. So, we got this laser power history, and then we implement the into RP. So, you can see ABCD you know, depends on where you are, you have different thermal history, and remember, we want that thermal history. So, we basically shifted, so, this product is because each point you have a different birth time. So, we shifted and compare for example, the thermal history that we want the dashed lines are the constant laser power and this solid lines are the why using our computed laser power. So, this is promising and then the other thing that I mentioned it was interesting is remember I talked about the second time period was using important temperature reaching is important. So, for this one, basically, after each simulation, you can accumulate calculate accumulate time, and go through the same exercise and this is you know, computed from the average point of view and this is our experiments to also you know, looking at the time spent there. So, the bottom line is, it is showing the advantages, but I think there's still more work that needs to be can be done to further optimize the optimization tool, as well as the computational the power. So, with that, you and I talked about the process design, and then the next point is about the process modeling. As I mentioned, earlier process modeling needs to be fast enough to feed into this process design and one thing with the additive manufacturing certain is the microstructure prediction. So, if you look at the powder bed looking at the microstructure and typically the best way you know, the absolute The best way is people use a face field method to predict the the microstructure and phase field simulation is pretty expensive. So, the question is typically people looking at just around the micro slice might feel micron by few microns, and could already cost quite a lot. So, the question is, how do we speed up this you know, because we we build a very large part and the male pool size is you know, 200 microns sometimes could be even bigger, right? So, the way that we do this, this is one example looking at the physics embedded graph network, so it is inspired by the graph network, but it's not using data training, okay. So, what you can see here is this is the seed grams and what we do is for each grant original grant it treated as a node. So, for the node we have the information such as temperature, ground orientation and ground volume, and then for the edge is where the physics happening right. So for the edge is actually we are solving the Arun k equations to to look at, you know, how that will actually calculate the liquid side The fractures also control the brain growth. So that physics pay a fixed physics is calculated around the edge, but what it does is build up the graph network. And to do this calculation, so it's kind of reduced order modeling approach, and then you calculate the free energy and then minimize that. So, by doing this, you know, this is a comparison between the PGM model versus the DNS. And as I mentioned, this is kind of the reduced order models, so you have less degree of freedom. And the good thing is, you know, it's it speed up quite a lot. And because of this now, firstly, you know, let's check how it calculate how it works, right. So, you compare for example, the direct numerical simulation versus the red Why is a PGn and this one you compare you know, the gram volumes are pretty close, as well as an aspect ratio coming up from these two different methods. And this is you know, reasonably well, and because we can do this, now, you can actually model a larger model right, because the computation is very efficient. So, now you can calculate a larger Vanya and then you can monitor kind of simulate multilayers So, what you do is you use a previous calculation as a result as a seat for the next layer. And with that, we can now simulate for example, this is two millimeter by two millimeter one millimeter simulations. And really, you know, interesting, you can see these grand girls, which is actually what also people find out in their simulation. So, the idea is, if you have these grands, then you can use also crystal plasticity to calculate to the mechanical properties, right. And so, in the crystal plasticity piece, you know, I don't have time to talk about here, but you can also think about once you have the crystal plasticity, they're still pretty expensive calculated, and then you capture how do you capture the plasticity behavior also more efficiently. So, the way that we do it is this was back to 29 T, and we use the numerical simulation to to generate lots of data. So here you know, because we know the material behavior is also a strength pass and low pass dependency, right. So, using the design of the element of proach, you can you can generate for this particular one, we use 10,000 different samples generated and then using the Deep Learning Network, basically, for that time, you know, we have the fully connected convolution neural network as well as the LSDM. And what's new here that architectural wise, we also incorporate the initial microstructure into this representation into this deep neural network such that it has a good you know, initial physics and because of this, you know, you can see the difference between finite element calculated which are the discrete point about the yield locus, as well as purely neural network based calculated as a solid ones. And they match pretty well and particularly, it could actually also capture the evolution of the network, which numerically if you do that, it could be very expensive. So, overall, you know, right now, we are actually trying to develop the whole package. This, the code is at GitHub. So if you scan it, you can you can find it. So the idea is, you know, for Jax am, you can use this one to simulate using the Jets, you know, the library as I mentioned earlier, to separate the thermal fluids and with the heat input with a heat input, you can also you know, simulate the local grandgirls and with the grandgirls use hand simulate to the crystal plasticity. And then also we have an FTM version, which you can do the topology optimization, so that I that ultimately once it's fully build up You can have location specific material properties coming from the additive, and do the whole, you know, code design, as I mentioned earlier. So, this is a long term goal. And we're coming, you know, closer and closer, which I think is very promising. Finally, I want to talk about process control. And so for a process control, one key part is also sensing. And in my lab, we have about 40%, numerical, numerical computation of people. And maybe 60% are experiment, experimental lists, and some of the students actually because they're covering both areas. But the point is, you know, for experimental implementation, we also need that sensing data. So what we do for this one is, we use the photo dye system, and which was originally provided by sigma labs. But what we did is we have these photo dices and lab with our laser laser path. And this is, I believe, the first implementation for the DD system, and use two different wavelengths, you know, Calculate, calculate to the relevant temperature. And, and then it's interesting that you can see this is the measurement. And if you take the second derivative of this temperature measurement, you can actually corresponding to find the liquidus and solidus temperature. So this is what we find that the Deshaies and liquids is temperature for this Inconel 780. If you look at the literature, there's a large range of the air of various people reported. That's not a surprise, because a little composition change, but changing our liquidus and solidus temperature. But the key point is now we can actually institchu measure that. And then when we measure the cooling rate, if you have lower cooling rate, this, you know, match with the existing hardware measurement, which is great. And also for high current rate, this one, we have a sampling rate could be up to 200 kilohertz. So for this one, we can actually measure a high cooling rate that the others were saturated and won't be able to measure. So, you know, I talked a lot about the DD, but we also have the high resolution sensors to implement for the powder bed. And the idea is, can we use this as a tool, such that we can do in situ closed loop control. So in order to do the closed loop control, first thing that we need to figure it out, is make sure the data is not too noisy, because otherwise you're going to get something undesired. If you look at the real time measurement, this is a different layer Assembly about actually this is following the laser path, you know, so the resolution claims could be about 10 micron by 10 micron. So the idea is, if you just put everything together as a lot of data in 50 Gig get by data just for this build. So what we did is we use machine learning based or to predict the map or temperature of the next layer based on the previous layer. So the the key message I want to this is also using the random forest method, the key message I want to come across here is that, that this definition of the features also involve the physics understanding about what's important. So when we put these things together, it gives us a good prediction. As you can see, here, you know, the prediction is almost you can think about it as a future. And with that, you know, the noise are gone. But also it's do capture some of the fundamental physics right here. For example, this one as the laser turned around, you can see that you know, first part is lower and then you can actually because it's a right turn around the temperature increase. How much time do I have? Well, you have a 10 to 15 minutes. Okay. Okay, that's good. So, for for process control. One thing is really important is actually we have lots of different data Coming together. So data fishing or data alignment is important for it. So for this one, we have the machine level control, as well as the CT scan, post CT scan as well as the in situ data. So, we put all these together, you can then you can see where the porosity are, and that will help to guide the the process design. So, it was also interesting recently, we had this sensor array sigma lab system, as I mentioned earlier, put together with the, with the, you know, we went to the Argonne National Lab, and instinctually, you look from the top of the sigma lab system, as well as X ray, which is a projection to the percussion about what's happening. So you can see that this is kind of we treated the X ray as a ground truth. And you can see this one laser is moving around, and here is the bell pool. And as you go around, you can also see sometimes it leaves, you know, porosity, right? So, the key thing, what we are looking for is we use this as a ground choose, but the question is, can we use the X ray set, you know, the the top view and using this, this set of experiments to train our model such that you can just use the sensor array to detect what's happening in in the, underneath this right, which you cannot see that from the top, but you can only see it with the X ray. So with this goal, we this, these are some details I just skip. So we took lots of data. And so first part is a notation of the male pool. And then, which takes a long time, you know, one minute per image, and we have 250,000 images. So this is a perfect occasion to use, you know, deep learning to help us annotate the MailPoet. So that's the first step. And then some of the other things, you know, which is not realistic coming from the prediction, we have to remove that based on understanding about the physics after it's done. And then we tried to corroborate the the MailPoet depths, as well as the top signal, right, coming, coming up. So I should change this, this is already accepted. So the point is, yeah, it's just recently accepted again, just a day ago. So the point I want to say this is actually from the top X ray photodiode system, you can see those peaks. And what's interesting with those peaks is also corresponding to the MailPoet, their ups collection. So, you know, many times when we think about this, you know, whether this is a noise or it's really happening, it actually it's actually have some kind of physics involved right there. But the other thing, which is interesting is, you know, you see additional peaks right here, which doesn't corresponding to the MailPoet depth collapse. And what's happening right here is actually their son geometric dependency. So the conclusion that we got from this set of the experiment is that it cannot be just to the signal, it's actually you need to consider what geometry are building. So the geometry factor has to take into account to whether it's overhand or just to you know, solid base. So that's, that's interesting. And the other one, you know, there's a little peek right here, but you don't see anything here. The geometry here is actually very similar to here. What happened is, is a sample rate of this one is 200 kilohertz hertz, and this one is just 50 kilohertz. So I think what we did is we pick up something that was kind of missed by the other other tool. So you know, lots of data and inaccurately look forward for the car. elaborations to analyze those data together. So I want to just kind of finishing up by saying, you know, physics based and data driven was has lots of future for us to look at this qualification, right. So when we look at the upside, you know, the sensing data from the top, we can pick up those things that you won't even see with the with the with a detailed X ray because of the sampling rate. So maybe we can use those data for combined with a simulation, we can do a qualification as we built. So the other part, which I'm going to finish up really quickly, the other process that we do in our lab, for the flexible manufacturing process is called double sided incremental for me. So for this one, you know, we actually build our own machine as well. And instead of using tooling we use to, you know, as I mentioned, the two tools, geometric independent tools to move around CNC control, and you can make very different parts, the challenging for the thing here is because of the deformation is all local. So to numerical simulate this, maybe if I take 30 minutes to build it, numerical simulation to simulate very well, it will, could be easily two weeks. So similar challenge in terms of how can we speed it up. And in application of this process is actually, you know, much faster and cheaper to do it, you know, with the various low volume production. So company has already been picking it this up. This is Nissan picking it up. And here in the States, you know, there's a Makino labs, also picking up you know, you can see all these different parts build within a week. And for legacy part, which is particularly challenging, if you have a legacy part, there's no tooling, no drawing available. And using this one, you can actually speed up with a week. But traditionally, you can actually take a year or more to get this part. So lots of control also going out, you can do the offline control to do the inline control to get the geometry right. So overall, you know, recently, we are also part of the ERC Engineering Research Center we call hammer, which is hype, hybrid autonomous manufacturing, moving from evolution to revolution. So the idea is you can think about all these flexible manufacturing tools as toolbox, and you can build other parts depends on what kind of microstructure what kind of material properties you need. So the key thing behind this is what I presented early looking at, you know, some of those future directions like mechanics, mechanistic AI, to determine physics needed. And uncertainty quantification is important. I haven't talked too much about this, but we have collaborated working on this reinforced learning is interesting, because then we can also as well as transfer learning to get to different materials. We can use this for process innovation for simulation tools, as well as sometimes you know, the human machine to actions. For example, the incremental for me, and sometimes English. Well, in the other process, you have human involved as well. But the other thing, I think a very, very critical is also bridges, designers and manufacturers, we need the database. We need the automatic manufacturing process, plan generation. We also call it functional metrology basically qualification as you build. So lots of interesting, you know, areas to go for. And I would like to acknowledge a group, for sure without them, we can do it as well as our sponsors with the federal as well as a private, sir, thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you so much for the wonderful talk. You know, it's very nice. A lot. A lot of things are going on here. I can see that. Yeah, it was. You're really actively working on wonderful stuff. Okay. Let's have a q&a session. And anyone has a questions. You can unmute yourself and ask questions and answer the question for your key case one. Oh, first of all, thanks for the great talk. Yeah, the case you're case one, you have the neural network connected to a differentiable simulation. And then you calculate the loss. And then update. Do you also update? Like both updates in the neural network and the simulation? Or you just Okay, how did you update the simulation? So the simulation, the simulation is a physics space dissemination, right? So the neural network is really representing the process parameter. So we actually run the physics bases simulation at each iteration. The difference is a physics based simulation. In the even in the for analysis, your gradient calculation is done automatically by, you know, jacks or tai chi. So, so when you do the add them on top of that, we have Adam, we use Adam. And basically you use that just to update the process parameter. Does that make sense to you? I see. And also, like, Are there any cases in like, the model will like the interactions between the updates of the weights in the neural network? And also like the simulation framework? Are there like some trade off for like, some interactions between these two? Yes. So if you notice, you know, the first time when we tried to do? Yes, I tried it. Let me go to the slide. I don't know which one, let me just if you there are too many slides. Sorry. Okay, close enough, I think. Right. So one thing you notice, for example, in case one, the laser power, you see that there's actually have lots of ups and downs, right, the change of the frequency is much more than the case two, for example, this is a very, very gentle change. And part of this is because this trade off, as you mentioned, I see. Right? Well, thank you really relate to Ching Hai question in order to, you know, utilize both, you know, simulation code and the neural net. At the same time, the simulation codes must be pretty fast. But it needs to be fast. And you have to trade off the fidelity, like the accuracy of the simulations. How do you account for that? I guess, higher tolerance, it's okay to have the high error. Yeah. So, this is as I mentioned, this is something that even back there. For me, I think I have a slide to show this, yeah, this one is this, this was our kind of, you know, we use a simulation and and basically, you can see the simulation experiments, right. You know, so, it requires calibration for some of those parameters to kind of give us some confidence that we can use it, you know, and certainly we are now modeling, for example, the detailed about the like mechanism, like rhenium flow in the, in the simulation in the experiments. So we are losing some of those physics for sure. And that's why in the current development, I think I have, sorry, try to get to that. Yeah. So for example, in the current simulation, right. So in further differentiable simulation I showed earlier was just for using this path level, but the path level, let's say, the temperature input, it's very much like just a gas in temperature to represent the beam, Laser Vein, but little detail that like, what you see the particle interactions, you know, with MailPoet, we didn't capture that. So the goal that we want to develop at this level is to use this as the input to that one, you know, and so the PATA level could be still computational efficiency for the design, but nevertheless, it's going to be more accurate with more physics involved and Okay, so more feature work is required. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Okay. Kevin, you want to unmute? Hi, um, thank you for the talk. It was very impressive to me. I also have a question about optimization about differential with simulation compared to urine network. And though, what are the example of those are trainable variable of the neural network? I guess, I can see. When you're trying to backprop Okay, in front of physics based simulation, you get the optimal laser power. Right? And I guess there is some other like, is this sort of related to how to control that laser power? Or? Yeah, so for this particular one, we just control, we actually, we can control the laser power depends on, you know, your experimental setup, we can also control for example, in our experiment, we can also control the base plate temperature. So that's another one you can put in there. I think also, you know, in one of our undergraduate projects, we also develop the cooling nozzle from the side. So if we incorporate that, we can also have the site cooling nozzle locally as another control variable. So I think, what variable to control, it's not that much limit in terms of the numerical tour, rather than experimental slide, you know, where you can control how faster you can control? I see. So I guess, his neural network, kind of like replacing those physics part, like, instead of like, implementing all those physics part in the physics based simulation, I guess, is some parties with replaced by the neural network. Correct? Okay. Right. Yeah. So reason we do that, you know, you don't have to do this, you know, I think you can also just using the read, you can also use maybe just as some kind of simple function to represent that. The reason that we do that is really just because it's pretty much in the same framework with the differentiable simulation. So you can use that, you know, integration wise, very seamlessly, right. So this is basically your trainable variables? And then you can, it's kind of interpret interpreter from here to here. And, and you can easily expand that, and depends on what kind of, you know, physical parameters you can control? I see. Thank you so much. It was a very great talk. Thank you. Is there any other question you can unmute yourself and ask? Well, I was really impressed. I mean, you're able to do the multi layer, and then, you know, analyze the previous temperature layer, and then use that for the next layer. And usually, we try to do that as well. But because of the, you know, the computational cost of the high fidelity model we have here is a lot slower than the model you have. It's, it's kind of bottleneck there. Yeah. So for this particular one, this is measurement. These are the measurement and not the computational. So are you trained a neural net? That's right. Yeah, we trained it becomes really fast. So the key thing we actually have a recent paper just accepted on this is what we learned is that to give you better prediction, you also need to have the previous almost the previous 2030, layers, data or together to use to predict the next one, because for this one, it's easy in the sense that it's only very simple geometry. So the recent paper, we actually look at all these different geometries. And you can see that the neighborhood as well as the previous build up, a very important so we actually we show that we need the previous 20 layers or sometimes even sometimes even 50 layers in order to give us a good prediction for the next Just there. In I think the computational time is doable in the way to think about the recording, you know, the recording will take time. So it's very much doable for that timeframe. So it's not going to be really useful if you want to do following laser point wise. So still layer layer level control, not laser point and laser pest control. Right, right. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Sounds good. I think we can learn a lot from you. On the 3d printing and the process optimization. Is there any other question from audience? While you cannot let's, yeah, yeah. Feel free to send me email, you know, and love to, you know, have some further conversations. Yeah. You know, hopefully we're gonna have more collaboration with you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you very much for this great talk.